okay for the three people watching our
stream right now I think two of them are
probably me and one of them might yeah
if you're watching and you're not one of
us please comment and we will we will be
as interactive as possible
I just love dough so maybe it's too cool
no it still says three but this is round
one of week six the Webster windmills
are playing the Minnesota blizzard and
we are I think the heavy favorites you
would say all the pundits are predicted
esto en this is can muster priyadarshan
on also joining the I don't think they
can see you but you oh yeah and there's
some lag too yeah so I think III think
it should be hopefully a very lopsided
match in our favor but nonetheless our
tiebreaks aren't that great were tied
for a second but currently in fifth so
every every game counts I think the game
started land with yeah it looks like
getting started it's just to open all of
them we have the sifter Bailey playing
board one against Matthew Jensen who was
if I'm not mistaken or 20 50 feet it
Blair yeah and the way the round one
pairings work is their board for plays
our board won an artboard 1 plays
Airport for so these are kind of the
most are the biggest differential in
terms of matchups so have a see if is
playing an interesting e 6 b 6 yep
alright so well against players who are
far more alright because you can have a
dynamic game yeah I think it leads to a
very dynamic yeah position I remember it
was like four or five years ago Hikaru
Nakamura assists and yes championship
and outplayed at least a couple GM's
with this sort of system for black
who else we are playing for us we have
alien ethnic on board two against Frank
Johnson
see if we can get that game again is
well underway
so Illya didn't know who he was playing
and he actually woke up like 15 minutes
ago and I was I told him he was playing
a 2100 and he was jumping with joy so I
think he's fresh to the game he just
yeah hopefully his mind is still in kind
of that I don't know sometimes when you
wake up like the calculations can
actually be quicker kind of nutrient
States or your mind is uh it's a bit
quicker and bit more fresh Illya plays a
Carol con when did this happen you
please he played it too human to games
on the previous weeks of pro-league if
I'm not mistaken oh I thought he was a
French defense like addict or something
I think he's starting to on the system
and seems mean his opponents playing
fairly quickly so far but ok seems like
another dynamic position yeah
very interested in our artboard for Josh
colas was making use of Deadwood today
against Andrew tang oh my gosh we just
had like this exact position in chess
face like we were preparing and this
should be fresh in his mind I'm pretty
sure this is all opening preparation I
mean you mean Josh had all just probate
no we looked at it literally like 10
minutes ago
right before the game oh I was showing
him the game between uh she Manav and o
Yanna let's see if we can pull that up
so I think they're following the exact
game so far and josh has spent only
fifty seconds for 17 moves so they are
literally like blitzing out there Mon I
think it's just been a matter of
remembering their preparation and this
game from World League sent me slow no
this came from Queens gambit declined
very long variation I remember I studied
this like three or four years ago and
probably a day after I study that I
forgot the whole thing but there's some
deep preparation this is a
Tashia line wesley so used to feed
another strong player I'm just making
sure the audience can see your whole
board right yeah that's a sure a lot of
time happens with media see don't mmm
it's it could develop a little let's see
if we can finish it just press or and
yeah if I've mastered this technique
okay so that should be better for the
audience and we have one one commenter
are you Chinese I used to be Chinese but
they hide inside what okay it's not
related anything to chess or protesting
so we will respond to pro chefs League
valid comments and someone says wow
Rosen at twitch from bot winning we're
happy to see some awesome viewers it
says there's only three viewers but I'm
not one viewer I logged out long ago
this I'm gonna share this on our our
Twitter and then maybe we'll pick up a
few Twitter egg people okay well let's
go back to the game in between and we're
paying George Poulos and I have the the
Eliana game pulled up so I'm gonna just
assume through
wow they fit they've played exactly the
same game I think oh wait this is the
wrong key maybe 2013
yeah probably yeah so Wow Wow so this is
the exact same position look they agreed
to a draw here and again and know the
game of the illyana's game a Yanis
played queen GA check yeah and I was
just perpetual check again I hope Josh
rumors before the game I told all he
needs is like good drawers fine
oh jaw is a great result especially
nightstand routing so I'm pretty sure he
does freshness mine I told him like five
minutes before the game started well
five minutes before the game sorry we
had we had this position in chest face
after and I was like a bit earlier yeah
I think you were probably like yeah a
few minutes earlier but I've kind of
regret not showing him the final the the
final moves of the game because we
didn't see this perpetual oh he played
h4 okay what is really the idea fruit
takes after I mean he can still I don't
quite understand h4 I think he wants to
move his rook away so most probably flew
careful he wants to play group d1 I
think that's the idea and then go Queen
g8 and 28 mate I mean I'm not sure even
what black can do really much so you're
saying if rook take F 2 is raised one
yeah I think he didn't want it like
Queen takes h2 but it doesn't make a lot
of sense in the sense why I mean if you
want to give up you could give a page to
conduct play something like a 4 maybe or
maybe him I also made it kind of thing
that he didn't see the perpetual and he
thought that blacks idea would be to
play h4 h3 and fixed upon H 2 and that
would be a very dangerous pass for black
so maybe he wanted to avoid that
I think it's pretty clear both players
are on their own now
I moved 23 yeah so it could be a fight
step on up so I mean Blake OH
I don't see any clear ways that I mean
actually lake h4 because I mean now the
only way I see white black can get the
phone back to say they take off Kevlar
goes on me licking c7 but if he goes
King c7 then I like roopd one a lot yeah
almost probably that's the reason why
you played h4 maybe he just warned he
wanted to push for more than at all
because after King's e7 roopd one if
they play root calf - there's Queen f7
check or King b3 Queen b6 it's still
King bass explain b3 should be still a
draw there and I don't see any clear
sweetie I expect group d1 on the board
okay let's move on to some other games
because a lot more time burrows the blue
wizard right yeah he's playing Shaun
Nagel see if IgM one of my friends
there is yeah to observe him oh he's
playing Sean Nagel who I'm actually
playing next rounds so this is a
somewhat important game for me to see
what type of form that Sean is in and
okay double fee and Cathal actually
earlier today magnus carlsen played the
same same line against I believe it was
illegal Gupta haka and I've been
following any games today it was
actually a very kind of infamous game
because Magnus hyung is queen and I've
had Jay didn't see it it was like a one
move tactical one move fork okay that's
crazy but yeah this double finger though
I mean it's just it's just a game of
chess no no real opening theory and okay
I think Dennis likes to play positions
like this which are not so theoretical
c5 okay winning I'm already liking
White's position I mean White House
initiative
so it's down upon but it seems like
there's a lot of pressure
yeah I mean I expect like to go Knight
d5 with an ID for something still strong
ID for run and the knight jumps to d6 oh
no I I defy he may lose a piece in that
line like for example 94 Bishop f8 9 TD
6 Bishop takes d6 Knight takes d6 if
flag goes like rookie son just Bishop d5
and the Queen 1 cm is unprotected mhm
and
so I actually think this is create
compensation for the pawn yeah I think I
think there's too many holes the black
space and also another tactic that could
be potentially sniped xj7 King takes G
sounds we fight 93 very quickly so maybe
goes me strike he's doing the same thing
he's forcing black to go 3 goes be
Sheriff Ed Bishop D if I lose at least
but yes you go Bishop b6 and then I
don't really know I mean here's
compensation but I'm trying to see what
way is trying to get the compensation I
mean I take g7 King G so any six night
seven of six Queen f5
no but then there's Bishop g6 oh maybe
okay I think what he's gonna do is
Bishop e6 Knightly something decent ye
six knight son of six Bishop takes d5 ah
that one's in the Queen takes g3 check
yeah a lot of alignments in geometry in
this position yes I personally didn't
like tonight b3 I think the knight would
have been a lot more active on e4
jumping to d6 he tried 93 in less than 2
seconds so hopefully he was calculating
something concrete's
I mean still the position even if he
doesn't manage to get the pawn back here
soon enough
active pieces together I only worried I
would have is like a black man I should
go Bishop d6 and take on a5 and the
pressure kind of goes down because they
might wanna face very critical piece at
this point oh wait
so we have a bunch of comments in our
twitch chat which I have not really
looked at yet there's some discussion
about weren't we on early as accounts
which we work we did start our stream
earlier in the season on Elias account
but now we're on our official web store
windows accounts
someone's getting or suggesting us to
get Hanson's hostess next time maybe
Ilya could hook us up with that Eric
Hanson oh yeah hostess on their stream
good lectures with st. Louis Chess Club
Thank You Mick loking or Mike Logan yeah
for those of you who haven't seen my
lectures you can check on the saying
let's just lob YouTube channel so go
ahead yeah I think my clapping also
followed us today is this the same
person who knew my brother who said on
the chair like this livestream two weeks
ago he knows my brother I think it's the
same person
okay remember the name I could be yeah
if you're listening to the stream let me
know if you're the same solo thing I
keep getting distracted but I'm gonna
share our link on Twitch and then we're
already up to 13 viewers so that's
probably including a lot of people who
aren't us yeah yes I'm sorry
so for the viewers as in the second
round it mode myself and Erica are
playing Ilya will be hosting their own -
and I don't know if there'll be any
guest hosts but okay so maybe they're
just repeating now yeah what over the
last few minutes this is give check
check check check
it's going to be a drama could black try
a quick queen b5 just cream yeah no I
mean you can try like that we need three
queens if I mean but the thing is after
Queenie three Queens if I even wait can
take and go root 3/1 you can't push
further win on that or you're saying
means if I Queen takes if I King takes
it fair and go root G one
that's where H four move becomes
critical the fact that you don't have
the h2 so the black cannot take group
takes h2 IC and rook takes f3 root G Phi
but still Raja yeah it's a great result
I mean you saw the opening preparation
and and Rohtang is very dangerous rapid
blitz rapid faster time control player
so making of half point is every half
point will help person overall die
breaks in the end
you know I we looked up at Andrews
profile before the game guess what his
one-minute rating is unjustly 700 it's
2950 yeah I've seen them actually play
the title of today's like holding
solidly against Nakamura a few games
I've seen him play and yeah I mean I
know he's a very dangerous I mean yeah I
mean very few players I think cross
3,000 and he's very close so but rapid
is a different story cuz there's enough
time to play accurately and not blunder
and it's amazing Josh has more time than
Andrew plan so we all prepared and also
he's doing good ok let's just do a quick
survey of the games
Dennis still has decent amount of
pressure after Queen d2 Ilya Wow what
just happened let's just go back so the
content Shane kind of led to some
explosion in the center should be formal
but I guess it's theory they were just I
mean funny Lee I am kind of reminded of
alias game against Grandmaster bori sick
from last week's protest League where he
went Bishop e4 to with black side on a
French defense and he just crushed Boris
like I mean the bishop is active on e4
it controls all the and also last week
just as Williams played Bishop e4 also
against is often on the opening so and
maybe the team move I mean yeah if
there's actually a song there's a chess
rap song if someone wants to look it up
I'll fill in the chat it's called chest
talks and it mentions this Bishop efore
move very specifically so Google chess
talks I'm loving it alerts push and he's
going to pick up the e5 pawn and then
the deep one of the start rolling and
he's just waiting upon it's just free
point actually I don't even know whether
Nidal go night has to go to a tree which
is a very it'll be a spot run go to d6
because Knight 6e 500 d6 night - to make
things even better if your earlier the
time advantage
here's how the story with yeah I mean 11
a half minutes about four minutes soda
would modern chess which is receipts
over seif Wow for my game because I'm
playing my
Jennsen and extra and seems like Matt
Jensen is burning a lot of time
wait well he's gonna get a triple beep
on wall Triple D phones we don't see
this too often but I think I think these
are strong triple funds yeah how did
this yeah let's go back just a few moves
so what is Dutch yeah they was names
owned in that yeah so it looks like
white never took back on d5 generally
black goes Aoife if I'm not mistaken but
then maybe he was worried that white may
go efore Fe a known IGF I and E 4 and
then they Bishop on I mean it looks like
White's sacrificed upon trying to get
some initiative but it seems like it
backfired
yeah and now it's just if we count
correctly
Black has not lost a single pawn and
despite having trouble pawns I mean
there's there's all that but I see that
beef oh yeah the idea is Luke f6 look
matrix this is a very dangerous
attacking idea I expect him to go route
81 now and then rook f6 and then play
Bishop takes d4 okay six go bishop h3
and
wyndi Fay yeah definitely like is
putting a lot of pressure and then we do
ponds I also like a seven minute time
lead
okay so black white wants to swap Queens
which means receive gets enough time to
consolidate his extra pawns
so like Wasif can go an ID Queen takes
d3 C takes D 3 Knight 95-year or D takes
e4 d take C 495 yeah so he managed to at
least hold on to one pawn if not both
the pawns which is good yeah so I think
we can expect wins from earlier in
recife that just troubled Josh's game is
oh and rest on this one he's trying to
figure out a way to play continue the
game he doesn't want a draw which could
lead to potential upset because if he
over pushes yeah and I expect him to
over push because he is he needs to
score for their team to have even a
fighting chance because they are
fielding compatibly soft power team at
2300 I have HD that's one of those team
situations which it's usually good to
put your opponent in a situation where
they might have to take way too many
risks to to create winning chances and
sometimes that's how upsets occur so
yeah good chances for Josh should be at
least a draw and and then yeah blue was
ours like Shawn Nagel gave an exchange
for so got some plans before it's to a
point yes I like blacks position and
Shawn Eagle has had some a handful of
upsets
the season he's defeated Conrad Holtz
and I believe at least one other Gian so
I'm definitely not gonna take him
lightly it's a bit suspicious because
during the light squares weakens the
white king a lot but I think he's going
to an ID for her because he has to
control that trace where badly or else
it's gonna be huge
oh okay
okay I mean seems like this is a closest
game out of all the games black as I
mean some some pressure yeah we're okay
3 over K 3 might Brooks III just try to
swab the ropes
yeah
as long as white can consolidate and I
don't you each is currently lose or
anything but maybe Knight f6 here seems
interesting with the idea of jumping to
e4
yeah the see Foursquare could be a an
issue for whites yeah so if a knight or
a bishop gets air it's very very
difficult to remove the fact is he can't
Gopinath I mean he can go Queen a
forward took takes a - rookie - that
slick he gives up three pawns in order
nice and once Knight comes free it goes
Knight d5 I mean I'd be fair is fine now
because there is no pressure on the f3
squared
okay I finally got around to tweeting so
the stream is shared with all of Twitter
awesome and we're expecting an influx of
followers so Emma clapping it says I'm
Spartacus
you know a Spartacus I think so Josh
finish this game so I guess you draw
yeah did Josh ago yes yeah draw by job
he got his job so half point and the
boat and that says something when our
board four draws Airport no they need
without thank you yeah that's good so
okay not a bad sign let's just get a
quick update on the sea fan Ilya Ilya
Lobby five was played and the night did
not move see one fine way to Anakin
England so the point is if pawns XP for
Queen takes e4 and white would win back
a piece so Queen e7 it looks like black
is stolen coupons because of the night
goes to a 395 and then the green ghost
might be you and he can even play Bishop
e3 it's greedy but k2 funds is a lot of
funds and central pawn D pawn is going
to win the game for black and I'm making
and the seif okay has lost his triple
pawns but that's one point of pinkies up
Aparna no because going to all three
three and that's and then you just
you're like rook f6 and seriously don't
give up okay so the winning ending and
eight-minute time lead not a fight
okay oh wow so Elia want a piece yeah
look at this white got maybe over a
weight mover ambitious might miss the
intermission before yeah it's a nice
move
so a little pressure before 8:00 Lee not
a night trapped
you have a point
he merely made that for her
tricky either for okay for Queen G fur
some of the Queen Mary I mean the night
Mary
he missed a three though I mean it's
kind of unexpected that the knight
strapped in he's a sworn bone if he goes
it doesn't manage to get the night out
without a we losses the night without
any rock pH so he did miss wait were
right in deep Leonidas
you know get this now it does just
parasitic
yes I mean it's I think he still has
chances I mean yes all that's three
minutes so intimately odo uses extra
rating points and
I'm not lighting damaged position this
this is like position perfect for
tactical shots like all the pawn and
squares near weight Kings I think yeah
it's much easier to play it with black
for the time situation but okay black is
thinking and if I get slowed in time any
green and I don't know I mean you can
trade it to change one pair of rogue so
troops e8 but this rook c8 means here
King eight
all the white piece our disco ordinated
that's the issue I mean not really
disconnected but I don't see a cohesive
blue I mean and it's hard to really
create anything for white and just kind
of have to sit and react whatever black
does and maybe move like being Queen g2
and just what we do King you do it okay
- and then you have well ons fight bones
yeah you might lose all your pawns but
if Queens come off the board at least
you're not getting made it like shipping
a few moves I mean he had a dream
positions with charnae - tremendous they
will get one and a half point on the
board and hoping that was safe and alias
corsets we should mention that this
match is brought to you by Starbucks
it's the reason why I'm alive probably
I'm probably composed of like 50%
Starbucks given the amount I drink yeah
I'm also Starbucks and I'm a gold member
for three years
Wow impressive you should put that on
your resume
yeah I'm one of the big contributors to
their profit margin I guess Oh tactic
alerts
I think scheme is going to be over trick
in blacks favor Oh 1987 I mean just take
windey taking h1 I have to yeah
well okay white gets two rooks for the
c-4 square we call it with a shitty for
multiple left whispered with a weakness
and deftly the cleanest burning their
majestically and that's what happens in
positions like this when blacks all of
wax pieces are coordinating and
targeting waste weaknesses there's going
to be tactics it's a little bit
frightening though I have to play Shawn
Nagle guy next so Julia the last kind of
interesting game I'm assuming the Cephas
winning the seat has already won yeah so
so he won his game he this was this is
the only game that he's playing today
because after this we have done mr.
Alexander Shimano playing on board one
let me message human oh and make
yeah we want to make sure our flares are
awake and alive
so this met the first round is actually
closer than expected and it looks like
the result of the match will come down
and I heard of I see if is also
following belief stream he just said
that you guys said this is the last game
for me today yeah see for following the
stream I have a safe one okay so the
Seif can if he wants to he can come to
our studio and join us if it's not lazy
enough to watch so I love it so fast
long tables yeah two ping-pong tables we
have in our studio wait why did wait
what just happened here okay it's still
winning for black King f1 the King
Kenneth I mean King f1 Queen d3 material
yeah I'm 12 more minutes
it's yeah 850 800 I see if said he may
come and do the live commentary with us
he said I will come also he didn't
mention it that's for gas decree fun way
well you really better be here in 12
minutes because we both have to fire
games I mean we have Nick doing the live
strange so he's our expert streamer than
yeah and very convenient but hopefully
he's he has enough energy after this
game seems like still yeah because I've
been Luke June 97
Brooke G Simon rookie oh there's not
afraid to it but still the bushes clean
does she I mean this
this much more
closer than I thought I don't yeah it's
good that Josh true cuz we have that
after they've been in trouble yeah
and I'm surprised that this Frank
Johnson has played very fair because I
remember the excitement as I go yeah
like one and a half minutes in the clock
and he still has like one and a half but
really I had the eight-minute time lead
and gets burnt like all this time on the
block
well we can see based on the time stamps
that but I certainly spent a lot more
time last few moves
yeah and this is a type of situation
where every second counts when
especially when you get below three
minutes oh I think he'll go Roop takes
the eight quintic c8 king 87 but then I
don't like the blacks King is very in a
precarious situation no and also I think
the d4 form if all of that happened
review models black
it looks like to keep looks like a way
to keep the game going at least yeah
it's not losing or anything but it's
just that I mean he's still a pawn up so
he can give up one pawn to d4 pawn and
it still managed to and if we go into
the slide like rook takes CA queen takes
the a king h7 then this night on e6 is
somewhat of a target okay
Illya ops for rugby eights so waterful
takes P it hoop takes P it Queen takes
d4 he's fine going into the 10th game I
don't see any winning chances for him I
mean there's a pass a point but put the
rook behind it and start pushing it but
then I just don't see so if this game
ends in a draw then it's 2-2 yeah
certainly not okay he's holding the
Queen which is good because I mean even
if he loses a six point of their screen
on the podium whoa
I've sort of 90s and ie7 Knight takes g7
Queen 37 f6 or even taking Oliver
neither failure
I'm always a little bit scared when the
GM plays a move that I suggest ug
between these six I mean 26
rikiei yeah it's still not losing but
it's scary and a white is getting the
okay I think most probably this game
will end in some sort of discovery check
and someone dropping a beast I mean I
think all three results are possible I
mean given the time situation given that
Ilias kind of on the the worst side of
this position but he's a much higher
rated player really anything can happen
I mean I said that were so once the
night comes Jeff six I think once the
night does come solid eight over there I
think that dress it's all I didn't even
if it was a six pond I wants the night
come to have six I don't see him okay no
issues if he goes rookie seven no Queen
da ting eight seven nine s5 check
tactics tactics so it Lea found in
defense the Queen yeah
so if we go solidly one ek the nineteen
at five he wants to a queen a favor
erupt xt7 that's bad
I don't maybe not bad Queen take the six
of cheese honking it I'm gonna make a
prediction and say oh yeah wins us I
think yeah with white having twenty
seconds left and Ilya playing all the
right defensive moves I think well maybe
he has a slight upper hand
but one always blue is that as that came
over I think it's what I would think so
yeah okay so one and a half points for
Minnesota at this point and oh no it's
one and a half one and a half the
current score line is one to one and a
half and this game would kind of differ
No so I'm going to play it by ear I'm
currently logged in on my laptop so I'll
probably play from my laptop and then
we'll have to switch the stream to your
laptop I think I can do that I'll play
from the computers over there but if
you're playing you need to play from
that it means I'm not life in their
quest yeah ok so this end this is
looking pretty Josh but
never Cynthia Petra
because what might win the rock but it's
gonna create past 502 I mean coming in
at critical
Denis is joining us I'm sure walking
slowly the pingas cup of coffee
I think it's tea yeah our water our
water
shaking his head wearing his trademark
striped shirts
what happened wish I thought instead of
night between id4 was far more strong
you
to do
I mean one and I'm one and I officially
have entered wrong foot
I perceive that and the judge drew
earlier
okay I think it's time for us to go slow
starts five minutes for the next game
time for us to yeah okay we have we're
up to 18 viewers which i think is a
record for the number of people watching
at one time I think it may be even the
combined all thing actually I think so
we've never had more than 10 viewers if
I'm not mistaken at any point in time
okay so olya you wanted a go
okay so we are going to take a quick
break alien is Nick is going to be
joining us or joining himself on our
stream perhaps with a few other people
so yeah I'm gonna pause mine and thank
you people on twitch we might post this
to YouTube later but don't say the the
windmills can pull through and hopefully
people are cheering for us so so long